[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs je suis très fier
de vous présenter le mannequin le nomic
dans mon décor qui est gâchée tel où est
charlie
essayez de me trouver mais où est il
mais c'est le monde trouvait ça avec ce
mec là en soirée ce que c'est que des
barres comment il va ça va être un des
plus fameux de bienvenue chez moi
pendant mon décor ce qui n'est pas chez
moi en fait mais réelle frérot ça tue la
chaussée alors se grille pain est
directement issu du court métrage que tu
as réalisé toi même label je veux pas
m'exprimer deux des dix millions si vous
avez été 11 12 millions à regarder qui
le contrat je blaguais ma chaîne youtube
on a une très grosse annonce à vous
faire juste avant que cette annonce déjà
bravo parce que je suis venu te voir sur
scène et c'était ultra culte
voilà merci mais toujours un peu de
promo j'ai sur ta chaine tu penses tu te
rends pas mes mots n'est ce pas par un
peu plus encore je suis au casino de
paris
à partir de maintenant n'hésitez pas à
prendre vos places mon spectacle de la
maturité
ludovic et moi on a une grosse annonce à
vous faire ça fait environ un an
maintenant si ça fait longtemps que ça
fait longtemps qu'on bosse sur un énorme
projet on est très fier on a bossé avec
norman sur une petite série qui va
sortir sur ta chaîne oui bon c'est donc
sur une grosse série
ça s'appelle aller je lâche le talisman
c'est fantastique c'est fantastique
c'est le genre mais c'est aussi
fantastique on peut dire le projet nous
y voilà moi aussi je suis dans l'impro
donc cette série qu'on a créé le
talisman c'est un projet faramineux
jamais me dire pharaonique way est un
autre objectif sympa c'est un projet en
indépendant alors que j'ai totalement
tout financé pas se mentir lui nous
habitions centimes voilà c'est pas un
truc qui va sponsoriser c'est pas une
pub comme j'ai pu le faire régulièrement
là c'est vraiment 100 % artistique 1 dès
le premier épisode du talisman sortira
sur ma chaîne youtube le 3 janvier vers
17 heures voilà donc soyez connecté
mettez des petites motif à elle marquer
le pas retouché vous donnant en incarner
deux personnages principaux ont sonné
bonne place le plaisir il y aura tjrs
encore de daïra on peut le dire il y
aura
pierre niney c'est faux que tu allais
dur on a aussi une petite surprise
évidemment on va pas vous laisser sur
votre faim aussi tout de suite
maintenant une bande annonce on
américain andy un trailer en allemand en
japonais
bonjour je sais pas ça et raciste dans
mes films d'action africain
bref voici sans plus attendre la bande
annonce du talisman tout est maintenant
3 2 à et on se retrouve on se retrouve
donc vendredi vers 7 heures ouais le
prouve leur parler après dix heures tu
as d'accord ok on vient de chez apple on
vient juste après
[Musique]
j'ai perdu mon grand-père quoi c'est ça
fait chier vous salue un héritage même
pas un héritage monsieur un porte-clés
mec tu verras nathan dans les moments
difficiles de ton existence se porte clé
ce sera utile sau qu'est ce que ton
grand père t'a donné en héritage ses
bras portent guère c'est un puissant
je peux le faire facile d'après ce
bouquin que je viens dire intégralement
ce talisman permet de se balader dans
les dimensions alternative de notre
réalité
mais je sais pas ce que tu fumes mais ça
a l'air énorme je veux goûter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
edf je les appelais way
non bon voilà on espère que vous avez
qui fait en dévoue vendredi 3 janvier
sur la chaîne youtube vers 17 heures
pour la sortie de ce premier épisode du
talisman évidemment à votre foi ma
chaîne abonnez-vous à la chaîne de ce
mec à vendredi
ciao ciao
[Musique]